TONIGHT AFTER
JONATHAN QUICK GOT
THE WIN F
FISCHER PLAYING IN
THE MIDDLE BETWEEN
ANTOINE TERRIFIC.
MIKEY ANDERSON WILL
PLAY BEHIND THE NET
FOR DREWBACK DOOR.
CHANCE, MOSER.
WITH A SHOT TOWARDS
I DON'T THINK IT
GETS THERE.
STRALMAN, RIGHT
THERE ON THE
AGAINST THE VEGAS
GOLDEN KNIGHTS.
HE HAS IT HERE
THE TRAILER WILL
SEND ONE IN.
OUT OF THE CORNER,RE IS A
LOOK AT JAKOB
CHYCHRUN.
THIS IS WHAT THEY
NEED MORE
CREATE MORE STALLS.
WIN BATTLES DOWN LOW
AND CREATE GAME.
CHIP TO GALCHENYUK.
HE GOES TO THE NET. HERE.
RIGHT BAR.
HE'S IN.
KELLER.
HE SHOOTS HE RIGHT
THERE.
KELLER WANTS.
IT HE GETS IT.
THIS IS
BROWN.
KEMPMPE WITH
THAT
BE A LONG-TERM
19-14 HITS FAVORING
COYOTES IN THIST.
OPPORTUNITY AND A
REBOUND.
GOAL.
HIS EIGHTH.
KINGS HAVE TIED ITCANADA WOMEN,
CONGRATULATIONS.
HOW ABOUT TO THEM.THE TIP, THE
REDIRECTION.
COYOTES IN FULL
DOUGHTY WITH.
IT ACROSS.
CAPOBIANCO RUSHES
BACK TO BREAK UP THE
GALCHENYUK, CROUSE
TO THE BACK OF THE BY BOYD. NEEF
THAT NOW.
HE KNOWS THE J